welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for our presentation titled
applications of high throughput gene
expression profiling and early drug
discovery it's my pleasure to introduce
you to peter messack a senior as
scientist at the bio gazelle and
associate professor of the faculty of
medicine and health sciences at penn
university in belgium for complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the tab at the top of your screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
those questions in the q a box our
speaker will address your questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter peter
you may now present
your
presentation welcome sir
so thank you for the introduction and um
thank you for attending um what i would
like to do today is introduce
uh
a novel technology basically two novel
technologies that we have developed to
enable height through putrine expression
profiling
with applications in
the various phases of early drug
discovery
the technologies i would like to present
today are shown here they're called hd
pathway c can hd target seek
so ht pathway seek is a technology that
enables height throughput gene
expression profiling
to reveal pathway level information
and from the path level information
various aspects relevant during early
drug discovery can be inferred for
instance the mechanism of action of your
compounds molecular toxicity profiles
that may be induced or repressed by your
compounds of interests or molecular
similarities between compounds that have
been identified during early phases or
early stages of drug discovery
on the other hand
i will also talk about a derivative
technology called hd target seek so hd
target c goes beyond hd pathway seek in
a sense that it goes beyond generating
pathway level information but also
generates
gene level information and more
specifically differential gene
expression
information and we believe this
technology can play a very important
role
during
phases
of oligonucleotide drug development
and more specifically
identifying on and off target effects
induced by
oligonucleotide drugs for instance
anti-sensory nucleotides or sir
now i want to just
take a few minutes to to make sure i
position the technology
and that it's clear where we believe
this can play a role so during the early
phases of drug discovery what you would
typically do once you have identified a
number of compounds of interest
that targets
your target of interest is that you can
use various types of assays to establish
the activity of those compounds so these
could be simple reporter assays or
certain phenotypic readouts but these
assays are typically
relatively simple in their readout and
therefore do not
do not reveal a lot of information on
let's say the mechanism of action
of your compound and what happens really
uh at the molecular level
and so uh what we believe is that and
we together with others is that
rna profiling
during those stages of drug development
could actually help in further
characterizing prioritizing the drugs
that are under investigation during
these stages
so
rna profiling has a lot of upside
potential here
you can use the rna profile to establish
activity of pathways and
biological functions
this type of information can complement
your phenotypic readouts
and help to further prioritize your
drugs so you really have access to an
extensive molecular profile derived from
these
rna profiling studies
and
important
to mention also is that
generating an rna profile is really
generic test
gene expression profiling does not
depend on the type of cell line that
you're using type of compound that
you're applying to your cells
the type of target that you have it's
really a generic test that does not
require any customization
uh depending on the project uh the
target the cell line and so on
of course there's a number of technology
requirements involved in order to
implement such
um to implement rna profiling during
drug development and for the first
requirement is that your technology
needs to be compatible with a high
throughput setting so the technology
should allow you to profile several
compounds and several different
concentrations and different cell lines
all in one experiment and in a cost
effective manner of course
and secondly
your technology should also provide you
with sufficient coverage of the
transcriptome
to enable you to infer activities of
pathways and to generate molecular
profiles in a robust and reliable
rna sequencing is obviously a technology
that
matches all of those criteria so rna
sequencing allows us to profile the
expression of thousands of genes
however in its current classic form
it's not really amenable to high
throughput applications
and
it's not really cost effective so we
decided to develop a technology that
we termed hd pathway seek that allows us
to apply an rna sequencing technology
but really in a high throughput and cost
effective
setup
and
the way this works is shown here so
basically we're applying this rna
sequencing technology directly to crude
cell lysates and this of course has a
number of advantages because we're
circumventing cumbersome rna extraction
laborious rna extraction steps so the
library preparation is actually
performed directly on cell lysate so
basically you treat your cells in 96
wild cell culture plates
with your compounds of interest or other
genetic perturbations that you want to
apply to those cells
utilize the cells we typically recommend
to use for biological replicates per
condition utilize the cells and the on
those lysates we actually perform this
technology so it's a three prime and rna
sequencing based technology and again
libraries are generated directly from
cell lysates another important thing to
to note here is the fact that we apply
shallow rna sequencing so in the hd
pathway seek approach we will only
generate an average one million reads
for each of the samples for hd target
seek we increase that number to 5
million i will come back to that later
but so sequencing these lysates at 1
million read coverage
we on average detect around 7 000 genes
in each of the samples and then of
course there's a number of data analysis
procedures that will reveal
underlying pathway changes
so let me just quickly show you some
some quality data of this procedure so
this is hd pathway seek data applied to
384 different samples which is a typical
number of samples that we include in a
single experiment so we can of course do
multiple experiments
so on the left hand side you can see the
cumulative fraction of the number of
detected genes so you can see that on
average
this is around 7 000 genes in some
samples a bit less and over samples it's
a bit more
the middle plot shows you the read
coverage so you can see that the read
coverage is really focused at the three
prime ends of the genes
hence three prime end sequencing of
course
and in the right hand side you can see
uh the reproducibility of the reed
counts that are generated so these are
technical replicates that are included
in the same plate and so you can see a
very high reproducibility despite the
fact that these libraries are generated
directly on cell lysates and were
sequenced at a very shallow
sequencing depth of 1 million weeks
next step is of course data analysis so
what is typically done is differential
gene expression analysis between
different uh conditions of interest your
compounds compared to vehicle vehicle
controls or other negative controls so
any type of comparison as possible
followed by a gene set enrichment
analysis to reveal the pathways that are
significantly activated or repressed
in each of the conditions in your
experiment
and so we use gene set enrichment
analysis because it's a very sensitive
approach
um and it has been shown in at least in
the class of non-topology-based pathway
analysis tools to uh basically
outperform all of the other tools that
are available we use various types of
gene set collections both publicly
available gene set collections from the
molecular signatures database but also
custom gene sets that you may have
available
we also did some analysis to uh
demonstrate that even with just 7000
genes you can actually reveal all the
relevant pathways that are
differentially expressed upon certain
perturbation
and so to do so we simulated
uh situations using real life data sets
these are three different real-life data
sets where we either use all of the
genes to do a differential gene and
pathway
analysis or just use the 7000 most
abundant genes which are typically the
ones that we detect with hd pathway seek
and then compare to the output of the
pathway analysis and as you can see here
um
the pathways that are shared between
both conditions so being
on the one hand side using all of the
genes on the other side using um
only the seven thousand most abundant
genes you can see that the majority of
the pathways that are identified are
actually shared between both conditions
meaning that
even with just seven thousand genes you
can basically retrieve
the relevant pathways that are either
activated or inactivated in your data
set
so we believe this methodology can
actually reveal insights in the
mechanism of action of your compound it
can reveal insights in certain box
pathways that
may
be activated
upon
compound treatments
but we can also use it for instance to
compare
the profiles
you have
generated with your compounds of
interest to profiles generated
for drugs with established
mechanisms of action and i just want to
show you uh briefly highlights a few of
the analysis that are possible and some
data demonstrating uh the the power of
this procedure so this is uh these are
results from a project that we did where
we screened actually 90 different
compounds
including vehicle controls and some
compounds with known mechanisms of
action as positive controls on the
screen so for a total of 380 samples
more or less
and uh so one of the positive control
compounds in this case was for instance
dsa trichostatin a it's an htac
inhibitor and so when we did the the hd
pathway seek analysis for those samples
that the differential gene expression
analysis pathway enrichment and so on
we could clearly see uh htac related
pathways pathways related to tsa
treatment
appearing among the top differentially
expressed pathways
induced by this tsa treatment by
anesthesia compounds so suggesting that
hdpc can indeed identify relevant
pathways that are associated to
the drug's mechanism of action
you can also reveal those dependent
relationships between
compound concentration on the one hand
and pathway activation on the other hand
so on the left you see an example of a
compound
where
certain pathways are only induced at the
highest concentration
on the right hand side you can see an
example of a compound where the pathways
are already induced
at the lowest concentrations and you see
a very nice dose-dependent increase in
pathway activity for the specific
compounds and you can really look at
those relationships between compound
concentration and pathway activation or
repression
you can also compare compounds relative
to each other based on their underlying
molecular phenotype so based on the gene
expression data and pathway level
expression data that's generated you can
actually create what we call compound
similarity matrices where you can
compare compounds relative to each other
and identify compounds that induce a
similar molecular phenotype
this is information you can afterwards
correlate for instance to the chemical
structure of the compounds or correlate
to the cellular phenotype that is
induced by those
compounds finally uh and
another application is uh basically
using those molecular profiles to reveal
potential cox pathways
so a number of canonical talks pathways
have been defined some of them are
listed here like dna damage oxidative
stress e r stress and so on and so for
each of these stocks pathways we have
one or multiple gene sets that represent
box pathway activity and so what we can
then do is to look at the induction or
repression of these pathways for each of
the compounds included in the screen
and by doing so you could be able to
upfront
during those early phases of drug
discovery already try to predict or get
insights into potential toxicity
mechanisms that are activated
when adding your compounds to to the
cells or evaluate at what concentration
do you start to see induction of certain
unwanted toxicity pathways
now this entire technology comes with a
very diverse suit of data analysis tools
that actually allow you to
browse and navigate through
all of the information because it's a
lot of information that's being
generated in a single experiment
and so these tools that we have
developed actually allow you to browse
through all of that information in a
user-friendly way i will just briefly
show you
what the tool can do so this is a
tool that you can access once the data
has been generated and uploaded this is
something
that is part of uh standardly standardly
integrated into these projects
so you can get overviews more general
overviews of the results or go into more
detail into individual contrasts and
again look at toxicity similarity and so
on just highlight a few things so you
can get an overview this is an
experiment with 72 different
compounds
you can get an overview of the number of
positively and negatively enriched
pathways and gene sets for each of the
contrasts but you can also zoom in on
certain contrasts for instance a certain
compound in a certain cell line that was
administered in different concentrations
and then see how the number of enriched
gene sets is correlated for instance in
this case to the concentration of the
compounds this is again a very nice
example of a compound where you see a
dose-dependent impact on activated and
repressed pathways in these cells
you can also zoom into individual
contrasts this is again the example of
the trichostatin a that was added at a
certain concentration to a certain cell
line
and you can actually pull up or reveal
all of the significantly enriched gene
sets that are either activated or
repressed upon treatment with the
compounds with all of the statistics
associated to them
links that allow you to review more
information about the content of these
gene sets and you can also select
individual gene sets and reveal
the underlying data so the gene central
analysis plots and to the right hand
side a table showing you which genes
from that gene sets are actually
contributing to the enrichment so the
so-called core enrichment genes
that actually drive
the enrichment so for all of these genes
you get individual statistics again
what was their fault change
in the
in the experiment and so forth
you can also reveal a two-dimensional
plots uh or or generate two-dimensional
plots that reveal relationships uh
between
different treatments so these are
different compounds that are clustered
here
um in a two-dimensional disney plot um
allowing you to reveal uh whether
certain compounds are more similar or
more related to which
compared to others
and
finally you can also reveal these
toxicity profiles these toxicity maps
where these canonical tox pathways are
shown and um with indication whether
they are positively positively or
negatively enriched
for each of the compounds and the
conditions included in the screen so a
number of tools that allow you to browse
through the results to generate figures
that you can download
and so on
so that's hd pathway seek and i want to
go one step further and talk about let's
say a derivative technology that is uh i
mean from a from an analytical point of
view in a technological point of view uh
identical to hd pathway seek but uh
differs in the fact that
we generate a bit more reads we sequence
a bit deeper to enable
really gene expression level
analysis
and
we're positioning this technology
really in the field of
oligonucleotide drug development where
it could have a number of applications
so um
only nucleotide drug development for
instance antisense oligonucleotides is
iras so these processes typically
involve several hundreds of candidates
that are screened for their
impact on reducing target expression
they're typically also selected based on
the on-target knockdown efficiency but
we know of course that these molecules
also have a number of target cheats
and what we think this hd target seek
technology can do is to help reveal
those off-target jeeps and and having
access to that information can actually
guide or further steer oligonucleotide
drug developments
you can for instance evaluate whether
certain chemical modifications may
improve uh the off-target repertoire
whether formulation of dosing or dosing
has an impact on the off-target
repertoire you name it
a second application
is not an oligonucleotide drug
development but actually in repurposing
data from
sir a or shrna library screens
so
these screens
are typically
or can be heavily affected by of target
effects as well
and it's been shown in several research
papers that
gaining insights in the off-target
effects that are induced during these
srna library screens that
these insights can actually reveal novel
players in the pathways that are being
studied and potentially reveal novel
therapeutic targets and i will come back
to that later to show you
a
study that we've done and that actually
allowed us to do
that now
the way this is normally achieved is
purely from a bioinformatics
point of view
where
the mechanism by which these of target
effects are induced are actually used to
predict
for each of the si rnas that you would
have in such a screen
predict what their off-target repertoire
could be so you probably know or you
don't know that
off-target genes induced by sr cyrnates
are actually um
of target genes induced to a
microrna-like action of sir so through
seed binding in complementary seed
binding
um between these ira and the target
messenger rna this is how off-target
genes are being induced and so there's a
number of uh tools that have been
developed that purely rely on
bioinformatic predictions of target
genes using the srna seed sequence
but there's a number of disadvantages
when relying only on bioinformatic
approaches so first of all
you can have many false positive
predictions
the seed sequences that we are referring
to here are very short sequences six
seven nucleotides in length
so you can find typically a lot of
matches uh for these sequences uh in
utrs of uh of of messenger rnas
so a lot of false positive predictions
and on top of that
these predictions do not provide you any
information on the magnitude of the of
target effects so
you may have enough target that
is regulated is repressed by 20 but some
other of target genes may be repressed
by 80 or 90
so there's no information on the
magnitude of the effect if you only rely
on bioinformatic approaches to predict
of targets of uh of oregon nucleotides
in this case this example is ir x
so by integrating gene expression data
and on top of that differential gene
expression analysis you can actually
further fine-tune the selection and the
repertoire of targets in such an
experiment
so by combining genes that are down
regulated upon sir a treatment with the
presence or absence of seed
binding sites for the sirna that was
included in the experiment
you can actually further narrow down
the list of of target genes fine-tune it
and on top of that also get an idea on
the magnitude of the effect the sir a
has on its off-target repertoire
of course doing that again requires
methods that enable high throughput gene
expression profiling a very cost
effective method and this is again where
in this case hd target seek kicks in so
it's the same technology as hd pathway
seek it's also performed directly on
cell lysates
um the only difference is that instead
of generating one million reads per
sample we uh go a bit higher here we go
for five million reads per sample so
it's five times higher sequencing depth
why
because um it
will provide you with a bit more
coverage on genes and have identify a
bit more genes
and really be able to do reliable
differential gene expression analysis
uh so going beyond the pathway level
analysis where you're combining
information from multiple genes and then
it's not that important to have highly
accurate gene expression readouts
whereas if you really want to focus on
the individual gene
readouts and differentially expressed
genes you need to have sufficient
coverage
so
as mentioned i want to
show what this technology can do
using a case study
where we have applied hd target seek in
an sir a screen repurposing study
so in this case this was an s iron a
screen that was performed in the context
of fibrosis
uh where the readout was a tgf beta
driven phenotype so with a tgf beta
reporter readout
1716 genes were actually screened
using this library approach with three
different siris per gene so a total of
close to 5 000 s irnas that were
screened
for their activity to induce or repress
this tgf driven phenotype and readouts
so hits were basically genes that would
repress tgf-beta signaling upon logda
and typically those screens will reveal
two types of
two types of hits two types of genes
the example of gene a is an example
where all three sirnas give knock down
of the target in this case gene a and
will also induce the phenotype of
interests so gene a here is a gene that
will be classified as a hit
where
meaning that gene a is involved in
repressing uh in this case tgf beta
signal
but a number of cases are actually more
like gene b where
um all of these iras would induce target
knockdown but only one of these iras
induces the phenotype of interest so
suggesting here that it's iron a3
directed against gene b
is actually mediating the phenotype true
of target effects not by knocking down
gene b but really by knocking down one
or multiple of target genes and so
identifying those genes could reveal
novel players in
the pathway of interest so there's a lot
of hidden information in these library
screens that can be revealed by applying
these hd target c technology and i will
show you uh what we've done in this case
so 86s irnas were selected that show to
this type of behavior
so with presumed off-target effects
a number of positive controls and
negative controls were also included
amongst others as irnas against the tgsb
receptor one and two
as known repressors while if you would
knock down tgbt receptor one or two you
would get regression of tj beta
signaling so these were the positive
controls
so applying hd target seek to again this
was a total of around 384 samples
um i'll just show you some of the
results from the positive controls and
then move to the uh the of target this
irnase so here you can see as iron
against tjf beta receptor one on the
left
teaches beta receptor two on the right
um we can the the methods reveals very
clear knockdown of tgsb receptor one
expression and tjsp receptor two
expression
we can also see that at the pathway
level these knockdowns are functional
you can see
a lot of tgf beta related gene sets that
are significantly repressed in both of
those positive control conditions
suggesting that we are
capable of detecting differential
expression of individual genes and also
of uh individual pathways
um
so when doing differential expression
analysis for these irons of interest
those 86 is iron as we presumed of
target effects it was really interesting
interesting to see that
for most if not all of these irnas we
could identify a few dozen up to several
hundreds of genes that were
significantly repressed
when
treating the cells with those individual
si rnas so we could identify both
up-regulated and down-regulated genes
but with a clear
bias towards the down-regulated genes so
many more down-regulated genes and
upregulated genes suggesting that
there's a number of targets there that
may be responsible for driving the
phenotype that these irons are inducing
so the proof of the pudding is in the
eating and so if this is really the case
then what we expect to see is that
genes that have a seed site for these
sirnas are actually preferentially down
regulated in the data
so before i show you the results i just
want to quickly
give us or give a brief overview of
these different seat matches that we
consider so this is coming from the
micro rna world where you have the
canonical seed matches being a six
nucleotide seed match a seven nucleotide
seed match there are two different types
of second nucleotide seed matches that
they're called a seven mirror m8 or a
seven or a1 i won't go into too much
detail we don't have time for that
uh or the eight mirror uh seed match so
an eight likely tight seed match
and basically these go in these are are
ordered here with the increasing
efficiency so the six nucleotide seed
matches are typically less efficient
than the seven nucleotide seed matches
which are less efficient than the eight
nucleotide seed matches in repressing
target expression
so what we expect to see if this is this
phenomenon is indeed playing a a role
here in in the data and that's what of
course you hope to see because that's
the entire hypothesis
is that if you look at genes
that have a six mer a seven or a one a
seven m a through an eight merc site
that you would see a proportional
increase in the fold down regulation of
these genes compared to genes that don't
have any match any seed match with tsi
rna and that's exactly what we see so in
the middle plot you can see the
cumulative distribution of the fault
changes for genes that don't have a seed
match in black
compared to genes that have a six mirror
a seven
or an eight mer seed match
and on the right hand side you can
basically see the median lock to fall
changes where indeed you see a
proportional
increase
in the lock to fall change down
regulation when going from no to six mer
to seven mirror a1 seven or m8 and eight
so really proving and validating that
this technology can reveal its ira of
target effects when applied in such a
setting on cell lysates
so in order to prioritize the most
important of target genes in this um
in this setting we
looked for of target genes that were
actually recurrent among multiple of
these irnas that were included in the
screen
so we decided to focus on off-target
genes that had at least one eight
mercedes
and of target genes that were at least
down-regulated two-fold
and so when counting
for every of those genes how many times
we observed such enough target gene
across the 86 different sirnas we get
the frequency table that is shown on the
um on the plots
on the slide here on the right
and what was very revealing is that the
second most frequent of target gene that
was identified was actually tjs beta
receptor one itself which of course made
total sense as this is one of the major
drivers of tgf beta receptor signaling
so this is really proving that we can
use that technology to identify relevant
of target genes from such in this irony
repurposing screen
and also interesting to see was that
several other of these top-ranked genes
were also known components of the
teacher's vita pathway
and interestingly of course for the
customer in this case is that there were
several genes in there that had not been
associated to teach you've made a
pathway activity before
so
i want to conclude by by reiterating
that the technologies i presented here
today being hd pathway seeking hd target
seek
are high throughput rna sequencing
technologies that are performed directly
on cell lysates there's no need for rna
extraction so they have the capability
to be performed in high throughput in a
really cost effective manner so
basically all you need to do is to do is
treat your cells with your compounds or
antisense or this iron a nucleotides
of uh
uh is irons of interest
um
lice your cells ship the lysates and
that's basically it uh we run hd pathway
seek hd target seek together with all
the proper data analysis directly on the
shift lysates
and provide you back of course with the
results
so with that i want to end also thank a
few people that have been involved in
the development of these technologies at
biogazelle
and also especially
thank galapagos
so for allowing us to share the results
from the fibrosis as irony screen
and
i'll
leave it here and thank you for
listening thank you for attending and
i'm happy to take any of your questions
thanks
thank you peter for that outstanding
presentation and we will now move into
the live q a portion of the presentation
and as a reminder to our audience
members please submit your questions via
the q a box
so peter let's take a look we already
have some great questions
coming in from our audience members
and it looks like
that
we are not seeing you on
your camera
can you hear me peter
now i just thank our audience
for their patience
that does happen on occasion
and
it looks like he is trying to get back
on
camera
so peter if you could just go ahead and
turn your camera back on
we will begin the live q a portion with
our audience
and again thank you for these technical
difficulties they do happen on occasion
and i see that there are already some
great questions so if you haven't asked
a question go ahead and use that q a box
and um
we will begin
all right it looks like he is about
to hop on
um peter if you can hear me
please turn on your camera
and
the right
i'm just going ahead and texting him and
letting him make sure we get him back in
here
every once in a while this happens and i
hope that all of you are enjoying this
conference so far it has been fabulous i
know i've seen a few of you from room to
room
um in our studios today but if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
agenda there are quite a few more
workshops and uh seminars throughout the
day
um following this one so
we hope that you will join us for other
webinars as well
and um
it looks like
he is still trying to figure it out
this is where i think audience members
begin
to see how long i can possibly stall
and i appreciate all of your patience
um
it looks like he is
almost in here
let me go ahead and respond please
go to the bottom
okay i've gone ahead and asked him to
exit the studio and then come back in
and i hope that the people that are
attending will stick around because i
think
he we are i already see the questions
that have come in and i think it is
going to
be a great live q a
so again bear with me
as we wait for him to
log out so he just logged out
and now he's logging back in
and we should see him pop up
i also want to encourage you to
work on that survey
so i know we've asked you a few
questions
um and we appreciate your feedback on
that as you proceed through the
different
various webinars
um peter can you hear me
i can hear you hi can you hear me yay
there he is
finally and i will tell you what i read
i will tell you what a great audience we
have every single one of them are still
in the studio so thank you to our live
audience we appreciate that
um welcome back peter
and we will go ahead and begin
our q a and it looks like our audience
members have already
provided some great questions so thank
you all for your patience our first
question peter is can this method also
be used with tissues or biofluids
yeah so um
thanks for that question um so basically
uh what i showed in the presentation is
that we typically work on cell lysates
this works this approach works well with
cultured cells and these are easy to
learn
if you work with tissues or biofluids we
would need to introduce an intermediate
step before applying the technology and
that stuff would entail an rna
extraction
um performed on the fluid or or on the
tissue
before able to do the library
preparation so the method is compatible
the library preparation method and
everything downstream of it is
compatible with tissues
for
an extraction
on those tissues or biofluids
and
deliver the rna and 9612 plates for
instance so it can work given that you
and peter thank you so much um
our next question is are there any
scenarios where you'd recommend using
more than four replicates per condition
um so
the muppets
that we suggest to use here is really a
trade-off between
let's say
insensitive enough and having sufficient
replicated sufficient power to detect
differential genes on one hand and on
the other hand
stay cost-effective
and this is always a trade-off the more
replicates you would include the less
cost-effective the method would become
of course your cost per condition would
increase uh but you would gain power and
would be able to identify let's say uh
differential genes uh that have
potentially lower fall changes a bit
more warm or that are lower abundance
i think
four is a is a good a good trade-off
especially if you're focusing on
differential pathway expression analysis
so the hd pathway ac procedure
for that four is is optimal
going lower would reduce the sensitivity
dramatically this is something we
simulate
going higher
may have a small
gain in in outputs but potentially
non-dramatic especially on that pathway
at the g level that's a different story
thank you so much peter
our next question from our audience
member how about cells cultured in 3d
such as
spheroids
well in principle if you can lyse the
cells
then
the method can work
perfectly on those lysates so if your
spheroid cultures can be lysed using uh
the lysis protocol that we've helped
this should work perfectly fine what we
always do is if we would deviate from
what we standardly do which is 2d cell
cultures we always do
a very small pilot
where we ask
the customer to
grow a few cells
at the license buffer ship as the
lysades and then we do a qc to evaluate
whether we can indeed generate libraries
from that type of material
so this is something we would evaluate
on a case-by-case basis but i definitely
do not we have not done it before for
cultures to be clear
but i definitely don't exclude the
possibility that this could work and
it's very easy to test if it would work
thank you so much peter
now what are the sensitivity limits of
the technique in terms of number of
cells per sample
um
so this depends uh in parts on the cell
type some cells are more
transcriptionally active than others so
depending on the cell type you can get
more rna per cell
what we typically typically in in 96
well plates work with cell numbers five
thousand ten thousand fifteen thousand
percent it also really depends on the
cell culture conditions and the optimal
conditions for the readout and the
experiment itself and the treatment and
so on so all of these things need to be
taken into account um
the lower the cell number um or let's
say the lower
the rna content
of the lysates
the few
genes that the methods will detect for
pathway analysis uh this is quite robust
so even when when decreasing the number
of genes from seven thousand to six
thousand to five thousand you would
still be able to detect a majority of
differential pathways for differential
gene expression analysis of course this
would uh have an impact
thank you so much and we have time for a
couple of more questions
peter how long would it take to see
these newly identified
as that are
rnas applied to fibrosis patients
so i guess this is related to the the
the case uh i presented uh in the
context of fibrosis where we looked at
this irony of targets
i don't know if the question is
related to
how long it would take to see the
off-target effects
of those iron ac
patients
that's not something we have
investigated so what we have done is
really the in vitro work the upfront
work where uh we looked at uh off-target
genes for sirnas in uh
that were identified from the screen
how long these if it would take for
these effects to manifest themselves in
patient samples it's
not something like that
let's get it so
thank you so much
um we have one more final question how
do you deal with variation and sample
concentrations across different wells
um because i
see that the connection is a bit
um
before we
actually start
seek
384 live experiments already quantified
and boots
uh to
based on the library concentration in
order to obtain an ak motor pool and to
get an even redistribution across
samples so there's an
a step involved that takes care of this
peter i want to thank you again for
presentation today and for your
important research and i also i want to
take the moment and thank our audience
members for their patience and their
questions any questions submitted but
not presented at the end of the q a
today will be answered via email
by the address that you provided in your
contact information thank you again
peter and thank you to the audience this
presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months and
please remember to share it with your
colleagues who may be interested in the
topic today and don't miss out on the
other presentations in our agenda visit
the agenda tab in the auditorium for a
full listing thank you again peter and
thank you all
until next time take care stay safe stay
healthy bye-bye okay thank you so much
thanks for uh for listening thanks for
attending bye